it is time for drew's news your hearty
slow cooked good news ragu and with me
at the desk best co-pilot in the biz
rossi ross matthew hi everybody hi
i'm a little al dente
i love that you were so nervous you
didn't talk to mark cuban in a
restaurant i didn't want to disturb him
and i felt intimidated so i just thought
oh i won't bother him and i have
deeply regretted it yeah ever since but
i get to write that wrong today well
you're so entrepreneurial too i can't
wait to see you guys like interact i
have so much admiration for him for so
many different reasons but i will say
timing is everything and if there was
ever a time to converse with him
it's right now because he's really got
some of the biggest stuff
going on and i'm really excited to dive
into it with him
okay so ross you've got the first story
well let's hit the headlines up first
we've got another iconic hairstyle trend
coming back to heads everywhere and i
for what i'm excited the independent
reports crimping remember crimping you
guys yeah well girl is back the 80s
poster girl for yes oh the reaction
and literally the headline is like it
starts out with an oh no
are you were you not a fan of the crimp
back in the day i actually feel the
exact opposite i love a tight crimp
crimp give me a crimp any day
thank you see we i love that we have
common ground on this i've never told
you this but my um first girlfriend
my first girlfriend was in eighth grade
and the only reason i dated her was
because she had a crimper and i thought
well an amber height
i thought
if maybe she'll let me crimp her hair
one day
and
well she was pretty stingy with the
crimper if you know what i mean so i
never did it i never did could we get a
crimper here could i crimp you one day i
you can have my locks and you can crimp
i'll be your amber and you can crimp my
hair
that is the sweetest thing a woman's
ever said to me i'll be your amber and
you can crimp my hair girl you almost
turned me straight right there now
almost almost for like an eighth of a
second a little bit um well next up
it's a story of the power of pancakes
the washington post reports that when
curtis kimball's wife told him that he
needed to make friends he threw a
pancake party
he posted flyers around his neighborhood
in san francisco saying my wife says i'm
getting a little weird so i'm making
some pancakes he set up griddles in his
driveway and a hundred people showed up
hungry for pancakes and pals
and then he did it again for 300 people
wow
and he hopes the idea spreads i know
i know
i love a man whose brain works like this
your wife is lonely you make pancakes
for the neighborhood and it fixes it
this is what someone who thinks outside
the box a little bit of batter can make
life a whole lot better better up as i
say yeah all right next up drew i want
your take on this one cnn reports a mom
named lorna made a deal with her 12 year
old son saver if she said if you stay
off social media until you're 18 i'll
give you 1800 bucks that's the that's
what you said to her 12 year old well he
took the deal and now six years later he
just claimed the prize yeah lorna said
like 18 years old he said give me the
money
lorna said her three older daughters had
a really rough ride on social media
which is not uncommon for teenagers so
she was inspired to sweeten the deal for
her son and it made me think drew you
know your daughters are going to be
teens you know in the next few years
what's the game plan with the social
because that's i mean
well it's interesting because i
i feel like yeah i'm you know what did
parents feel like when that radio rolled
in or the television or the home
computer
a lot of different generations have had
to deal
with the complexities of the onslaught
of information but nothing has ever been
this like ubiquitous
um
it's a tough time for parents of course
um
we just there's no manual for parenting
let alone parenting in a social media
age and we'll find it along the way but
pay attention to when you think too much
exposure i don't know what's happening
and when it's too little when i'm being
overprotective my kids watch tick tock
they love tik tok you know they'll watch
a youtube or they'll you know i'm like i
don't i don't want you to have accounts
there's the balance you're too young the
stakes are never higher when you're a
parent
it's like you will do anything for your
kids and to protect them and when all of
this stuff is being thrown at us it's
it's
challenging yeah but we have to figure
it out can i just ask a question why are
we negotiating with children how about
just like why why are we paying them now
how about just give me your phone
give me the phone
you're not on
well rossi i think you'll make a very
good parent yes
you hear that willie i'm gonna be a
great parent
[Music]